[Music]
have you heard this latest from
President Obama yesterday in an
interview President Obama once again
called Kanye West a jackass we good
apetite yeah in other words in other
words President Obama's finally found an
issue that can bring this country
together I believe hard core social
conservatives liberals everyone's
together on this why I think even Kanye
agrees of course Mitt Romney now is the
the GOP candidate Mitt Romney's now
promoting a message that his economic
policies are better for women that's
what he's saying
yeah not helping though is Mitt Romney's
new slogan Mitt Romney Mo Money for the
[ __ ]
they love that slogan Levi didn't yurt
hump did you ever want to hear noise
backstage a second you hear that stuff
tumble backs did you hear that yeah yeah
somebody knocks something over no I'm
out here you know I'm in the zone out
here right one thing what are they
building an ark backstage no now we have
an Internet fishing tackle business back
okay
Newt Gingrich not happy today Newt
Gingrich is blaming the failure of his
presidential campaign on Fox News that's
what he said yeah yeah newts also
blaming the failure of his diet on
Cinnabon
I think we cut to her cuz it's that much
closer to her birthday yeah we're
getting very close to your birthday now
it's only 44 days away now you're that
JK Rowling has a novel now aimed at
adults about this
Harry Potter author JK Rowling has
revealed the title of her first novel
for adults
yeah it's called Harry Potter and the
30-year adjustable rate mortgage is so
insulting to people like Harry Potter
what am i doing this week marks the
tenth anniversary of the FDA's approval
of Botox you know that yeah yeah to
celebrate people here in Hollywood tried
to make an expression
got to mention this Pizza Hut
you may have heard is coming out with a
pizza stuff with octaves in the crust a
pizza stuff with hot dogs in the frost
and hold your applause and Burger King
is testing out a bacon sundae yeah you
know things are getting out of hand in
this country when McDonald's has become
the healthy alternative I'm going to
McDonald's on doctor's orders I'm going
for a job better eat these fries at a
Denver Airport and if you heard about
this a woman was detained after she
stripped naked while going through
airport security yeah
the woman's either crazy or from 10
years in the future
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's where it's all headed
oh you have been drinking if you think
what's under here is I'm like a rented
lab skeleton I gave you don't want to
see under this hood I did hear some nose
yeah their shrieks of horror this one
that much bright white light coming at
you
you can see me from space in the night
it's very helpful you help guide a lot
of ships in the bombs come in get Orion
to take your shirt off coat in with your
chest so bright would you guide my
sleigh tonight it's not funny
it's ruined my life